[Musik]
hey leute wir haben heute so richtig
durst der hanser und ich und wir
brauchen mehr abkühlung also so wie
schon so eine erfrischung so ein
bisschen zu summer feeling
urlaubsfeeling für zu hause und da habe
ich mir zum cocktail überlegt habe ich
letztens auf instagram gezeigt und jetzt
bin ich das schuldig das jetzt hier
nochmal zu zeigen das ist wirklich so
30 sekunden rezept ganz schnell
zusammengemixt aber dafür richtig lecker
so haben das schräge normal oder zehn
zutaten die sind auch sehr überschaubar
hier haben wir erst ein ganz frisch die
mitte
die habe ich schon raschen hier habe ich
erdbeer sirup und holunderblütensirup
gibt es fertig zu kaufen und eine
flasche mineralwasser schön eiskalt
später schnappe ich mir noch ein
bisschen frische minze ist auch immer
gut im cocktail und das war es
eigentlich schon aber eine ganz ganz
wichtige zutaten noch eis also ich habe
jetzt hier keine eiswürfel sondern eine
riesen eiskugel und die gibt's bei uns
im shop und weil die so besonders ist
widme ich diese eiskugel jetzt dieses
video weil dadurch macht einfach diesen
cocktail noch mal so richtig besonders
hat mir ganz einfach leitungswasser
eingefüllt und jetzt nämlich erst einmal
hier raus aus der form deshalb aus
silikon deswegen das auch super easy
einfach raus plumpsen lassen und die
gebe ich jetzt schon mal so in ein glas
diese woche möchte ich groupies mächtig
um das tolle ist dass ich nicht nur
einmal benutzen könnt sondern diese
eiskugel schlägt ihr zimmer
was war ein bisschen laut die hält jetzt
auch die ganze zeit das heißt ich mache
jetzt meine sirup rein und meine früchte
und genau die schweiz die so schnell und
ich habe letztens mal freunde zu besuch
gehabt und mit den ganzen abend aus
dieser kugel getroffen bei der abends
ende und dann war auch die kugel
geschmolzen quasi irgendwann nach
stunden dann geht das auch super easy
ihnen durch einfach erdbeer und
holunderblütensirup und füllt das jetzt
einmal auf und dann geht es auch schon
weiter
deswegen jährlich so schrecklich
herunter blüten zero es ist so lecker
hier kommen bisschen geht noch oder
können uns heute wie du willst
da gebe ich jetzt auch frische
aufgeschnitten also halbierte erdbeer
ein ich würde es auch nochmal es sieht
nicht nur schön aus es gibt auch
tatsächlich so ein bisschen geschmack ab
und ein bisschen frische warte man
gerecht aufteilen
aber an diesem ja da schmeckt wirklich
mache ich gleich jetzt nimmt noch immer
eher damit der saft schön austreten kann
und er jetzt muss ich mir kurz messer
holen meine besteckschublade ist nicht
aufgeräumt
so die limetten habe ich jetzt hier
einmal in scheiben geschnitten und
halbiert und die gehen jetzt auch noch
mal so richtig den frischetheken ihr
könnt natürlich auch zitrone nehmen die
können die mieten da habt und was
hierbei auch unverzichtbar finde das ist
frische minze die habe ich persönlich
immer da ich hoffe ich mich eben ganz
schnell ab so einfach reinschmeißen das
natürlich schon alles gewaschen und das
einzige was jetzt machen müsst ist das
ganze mit kaltem mineralwasser
überwiesen am besten sprudelt also legt
schon säure ist auf jeden fall viel
leckerer also doch so einfach sagt sie
damit würde ich mal klar damit du das
auch machen kannst ich mich doch mal
damit möchte ich hier schon so ist es
auch total lecker so und das war es auch
schon fertig sind unsere erdbeeren oder
ich lasse es so tatsächlich also klar
man kann das umrühren aber es vermischt
sich einfach sowieso irgendwann mal also
da unten setzt sich dann der sirup aber
was ich so gerne mag ist dass er sich
unten absetzen ist das ganze getränk
nicht ganz so süß und ich will dann
immer im laufe des abends immer
mineralwasser nach und dann habe ich
total lange was von diesem getränk habe
ich mich letztens auch so gemacht
ja das ist in keinerlei fassen wir uns
das schmecken
das sieht auch richtig hübsch aus mit
der roten farbe unten schön ja wenn ihr
möchtet dass ich mir mehr solcher
rezepte einfallen lasse dann schreibt es
mir hier unten in die kommentare
in der video beschreibung schreibe ich
euch dann ganz genau die mengenangaben
was ich dann jeweils für ein glas
verwendet hat wie viel und was ich auch
dazu sagen muss natürlich kann man
holunderblütensirup und alles selber
machen wird auch total der fan von
selber machen aber wenn ich bei denen
bett ganz spontan cocktail trinken will
dann habe ich keine lust auf ein kochen
und abkühlen und machen und frisch zu
finden und wenn man will ja auch ganz
schnell was trinken und sich schnell
erfrischen
okay wir lassen uns das jetzt schmecken
und euch einen wunderschönen tag
schreibt uns auf jeden fall in die
kommentare und dann sehen wir uns beim
nächsten video channels
[Musik]